Alzheimers ease is a physician cause
disease it did not exist 43 years ago
today it's the number four killer
battles for the age of 65 it's a simple
nutritional deficiency disease a big
study done by Johns Hopkins came out in
2004 showed that they could actually
prevent alzheimers disease and they
controlled double-blind randomized study
on 5000 people over a 10-year period
with a special dot restricting certain
foods and supplementing with nutrients
right and in February of 2012 the FDA
came out and said well give up staunton
drugs because standard drugs the drugs
that lower cholesterol actually increase
your risk of Al Jarreau disease and type
2 diabetes
do not take statin drugs that's because
when you have Alzheimers ease your brain
loses the myelin which is the insulation
material and myelin is 100 percent
cholesterol there are 4 other dimensions
bastard dementia Korsakoff syndrome or T
Korsakoff syndrome and Alzheimer's
disease in Alzheimer's disease also
there is the dementia that's caused by a
vitamin b12 deficiency goes along with
pernicious anemia so all 90 essential
nutrients 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids essential fatty
acids 6 eggs a day per 100 pounds of
body weight poached also I would throw
in the D stress capsules three of those
three times a day when a person has
dementia I take that many just to
prevent dementia